i don't watch a lot of professional golf
but i i read the news there's a golfer
john
rahm john rahm is a spanish golfer he
was playing in the memorial tournament
uh he was doing very very well he was
leading the tournament
by six strokes man he was playing better
than any other golfer in that game
but now he's got to pull out do you know
why he's got to pull out because he
tested positive for covid
how do you know he tested positive for
covid well he just he took a test he
took an exam
you wouldn't know by his physical
appearance because not only does he seem
perfectly healthy
he seems healthier than all the other
professional golfers
but because he tested positive for the
kung flu
because maybe he has a cough even though
it doesn't even seem like he's got that
he has to pull out of the tournament
loses his chance at 1.6
million dollars 1.674 right now
uh maybe he can enter the covid lottery
where whereby states are bribing people
to take the vaccine maybe that's his
chance of making a million dollars
because he ain't gonna do it
uh in this tournament this guy's
obviously fine
this virus obviously has
as a matter of what we can see as a
matter of what we can what he can feel
in his body
no effect on him whatsoever but we got
to shut the world down for it right
we have to go get the vaccine don't we
listen i'm just as shocked as you are
that we are still
on youtube but there's a fair chance
you're not getting notifications right
now
the way to get notifications or to even
have a chance to get notifications
you ring that bell you like you
subscribe you will get the notifications
then by the way head on over to the
audio podcast apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher wherever you get
your podcasts
type in the michael noel show subscribe
we'll see you there
[Music]
you